the people of Staten Island did nothing
these are people who who pay taxes and
support a machine and say leave me out
of it I don't care about politics I
don't think about that stuff that's the
one Republican Borough there you go and
then one day they wake up and there's a
bus being shipped in of non-citizens and
they're saying hey your tax dollars
everyone's got a pitch in for these guys
and they're like wait these 20 year old
men from El Salvador and well sorry not
El Salvador Salvador is doing really
well everyone's moving back but from
Guatemala no seriously though but from
Honduras and Guatemala who are fleeing
here then when they come out and they
say hey get this bus out of here the cop
looks them straight in the eyes with a
joker grin and says I will crack you
over the skull if you stop what we are
doing to your home and then what happens
the cops beat and arrest the people who
live there to protect the non-citizens
yeah this is unsustainable you know it's
it's insane I guess though that's my
point is that even the the Republican
Borough with the tough Italian Staten
Islanders most people haven't even heard
this story